what's up candace how we doing good how
are you
good everything going well yes
everything is fantastic all right so how
can i help what's up
so i am 41 and i've struggled with my
weight all of my life
and uh in surgery i took the big step to
have weight loss surgery
and um basically i realized like it's a
tool and i still need to do
a lot of work it's not gonna fix
everything for me
yes i want to get to the root
of emotional eating and so that i can
have a success long term for my kids and
my husband and myself
oh very cool thank you so much for your
trust and call here so
um to recap you just had weight loss
surgery how recently did you have this
in january beginning of january oh so
super
recently yeah okay so
um have you seen just the the the
weight loss dive that just falls off at
the very beginning
yes definitely has lost 60 pounds 60
pounds congratulations
okay awesome so um
your call is a little bit muffled so
you're asking about um
or you're understanding now hey this
weight's falling off
yet um candace went with candace
before the surgery and after surgery and
you're still the same beautiful woman
looking at yourself in the mirror
and you're recognizing that same
six-year-old girl still looking back at
you
and you want to know how to get to the
root of this thing for the listener
you're 60 pounds down this is confetti
falling from the ceiling everybody's
cheering
yeah what are you still feeling though
um i guess so what it comes down to is
my parents i've brought them to my life
struggle with weight
and i um now you know
like they're in the 60s and their health
is really not good
and part of what helped me have this
push to do this was
i want to be the grandparent that's able
to do stuff with my grandkids and i want
to be
active and i just want a healthy future
and so
um i guess just seeing their struggle
and and where they're at has really just
made me go okay i need to do everything
that i can do
and um yeah and i just
i guess i need to find some other sort
of coping mechanisms
yes so what are
is there anything big that you're coping
from or is this just the model you
picked up for everyday life
meaning i would ask what your aces score
is what
your adverse childhood experiences did
you have trauma as a kid did you have
abuse as a kid
or were y'all just a family who
loved eating and y'all were just a
larger family
um good question it's um
i guess maybe um kind of both like
um i i have two siblings and they
and my sisters both of them neither of
them struggled with weight
so okay um yeah but it
it comes down to like i think it stems
from
i when i hit elementary school age i was
bullied a lot in school it wasn't until
about high school that i actually
enjoyed some of my school years
and so i think that definitely played a
part
um but yeah like no abuse really
just getting middle school can
lodge itself in our souls man and it can
stay there for a long time
so what did those what did those evil
middle school kids what did they pick on
you about
they picked on me about my weight so it
was something i was already
sort of feeling insecure about so like
as early as i can remember it's kind of
been
and middle schoolers are ruthless yeah
yeah for sure um and so are you able to
something has happened now that you've
lost 60 pounds and you've got
um so much more to go something has
emerged here
that has made you go oh this is just a
tool
not a solution what's popped up the last
few weeks
um well like i said like my
i've watched my dad's health go down no
no not that not that what's what about
you
you're so good at deflecting you're
you're really good at this
what have you experienced over the last
few weeks
um i will i think it comes down to the
fact that
i've kind of replaced that um
behavior like so i haven't been
emotionally eating but i
sort of replaced the behavior with like
just staying busy
and i'm getting to the point where i
realized like
i can't just stay busy and distract
myself all the time because
i'm getting tired yeah okay all right
yeah and so when you get tired and you
plop down just to
watch a show with your husband yeah is
that when the
old food demons come out or just the
default i don't call them demons just
the
the default behaviors um
yeah i would say yeah i mean
my husband's really supportive but he
often will have a snack or whatever when
he watches a show and i
just kind of sit beside him and just try
not to partake in that
i'm not hungry right hey that is a
losing uh
you're better you're a better woman than
me man i can't sit there when someone's
eating a snack and just watch it happen
right
um so here's the thing in the short term
what you're gonna do the couple a couple
things here
i want and you probably went through
some sort of did you go through some
sort of pre-surgery
they give you stuff to read or
counseling or anything like that before
the surgery
um yeah you had to meet with a dietitian
for
six months and yeah okay
did they walk you through there there is
it's very
common when somebody loses a lot of
weight all at once
like on the back of a surgery like this
that there ends up being some major
relational challenges
not that it can't be overcome but it
just changes the dynamic
did they talk to you about that no
they did encourage me to to you know
speak like
counseling or speak a psychologist but
unfortunately like my husband is a
pastor so
we don't have it's not something you
make a lot of money at so it wasn't
something we could pay out of pocket for
so gotcha so here's what i want you to
do
i want your husband to go to his
church leadership and i want him to ask
them
to pay for you all to go to a few months
of marriage counseling
during this transition time and not that
there's anything wrong
but you are going to need to learn new
tools on how to talk to each other
how to have fun together it's just going
to change the dynamic of your
relationship
and as some of the walls come down
metaphorically and figuratively some of
those middle school voices are going to
come back really loud
okay and they will make their way out in
your relationship in weird ways
it's just some of his basic hey i just
want to sit down on the couch he just
wants to plop down the couch and grab
something to eat
he's gonna need to be a part of the
whole family's healing
right and it's easy for that to turn
into
little seeds of resentment or
frustration like oh i just wanna
but it right and so what you wanna do is
head that stuff off way
upstream and so i don't know any
group of church leaders who wouldn't
help out their pastor in this way
and it's the right thing for them to do
they can afford it and
they need to make that available to
y'all okay okay
and so if if i'm him i'm having that
conversation at my next elder's meeting
or i'm reaching out to somebody tomorrow
right um and then the second thing is is
i want you
to maybe for the first time think of
things that you
love that you absolutely
love that you love to do that you've
always wanted to try that you want to be
interested in
you're going to need to learn new things
and this is part of the frustration and
part of the
super excitement here okay
you are entering into a whole new
adventure and it's not just gonna be
everything the way it was candace minus
a hundred pounds
what's your final goal do you have a
final goal there yeah
i'd like to reach 160. yeah you want
you want that to be your final weight or
you want to be have lost 160 pounds
oh sorry no so lose 100. okay all right
awesome um so that be your final goal
you know you hear me say this on the
show a lot whatever you end up doing
however wonderful your goals
and adventures are always remember that
wherever you end up candace goes with
you and you want candace to know some
new tools have some new
skills to have some new things that she
loves so that when you are down 100
pounds
you're not just the same those same loud
voices the same
patterns the same repetitive things that
you do the same habits in your life
you want to have a whole new set of
tools to draw from
right so after you get home instead of
sitting down watching the couch we just
go for walks because that's what we do
and we have a joke of the day we tell
our
favorite thing of the day and the
hardest part of the day we go to the gym
together
we're not ever going to a stupid gym i
hate the gym
but we're going to do some exercises in
our garage together
we're gonna go out with the kids and
kick a soccer ball until i'm so tired i
am laughing so like whatever those
things are
and they're gonna be awkward and wonky
at first
and then you're gonna say after two
months i hate this i don't like whatever
this is
or you're gonna think i never ever ever
dreamed i would love kicking a soccer
ball with my kids but now i love
love it and in fact i love picking up
the soccer ball and drilling one of my
kids with it that's even funny right
whatever those things are
knitting singing songwriting writing a
book
writing a blog whatever those things are
learning algebra for the first time
i don't care what it is but i want you
to spend some time with your husband
dreaming about what life's going to look
like what life can look like
get real clear pictures together and
then just start trying cool stuff
just start learning new habits if you
spend your whole life
trying not to do things that's got a
short-term
life to it okay you are
changing who you were into i'm the kind
of per
not the kind of person i'm not going to
lose 100 pounds i'm the kind of person
who plays soccer with their kids
right i'm the kind of person who always
has a joke ready i'm the kind of person
who
will wrestle with my kids on the floor
i'm the kind of person who will
pour ice down my husband's back while
he's sitting on this recliner or
whatever the things are does that make
sense
totally i want you to um order atomic
habits
by i just lost it yeah james clear duh
um i want you to order that book atomic
habits by james clear
and i want you to read that book it is
um simple
clear no pun intended i see what i did
there
and it is a remarkable book on how to
learn to live
with a different path in a different way
and
i think you will really benefit from
that book i want to tell you
i am so excited that you've decided
you're you're reverse engineering a long
beautiful
life which is i want to be 80 rolling
around on the floor with my grandkids i
want to be able to
sit on the floor with them and play
legos or blocks or
dolls or dinosaurs or whatever kids do
by then i don't know you'll be in some
digital universe of some sort but i want
to be able to play with my kids i want
to be able to take him to the zoo
and laugh i want to be able to fill in
the blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and that means i got to start changing
who i am and my health and behaviors
and life now and that's going to alter
my marriage it's going to alter my kids
it's going to alter my faith life it's
gonna alter everything
and so i'm gonna do the things up right
now they're gonna make that possible
good for you for taking a big scary step
and having the weight loss surgery
you're down 60 you were more than
halfway to your goal
but now the real work starts which is
changing candace's
picture of herself which is changing
candace's behavior
which is changing candace's and her
husband's marriage
which is changing the household
little step by little step by little
step i'm so proud of you
check out that book make sure your
husband calls um
his his leadership team and they're
going to pay for all to go to counseling
for a few months
they've got to they've got to they've
got to if they don't i've got a
partnership with betterhelp
so go to betterhelp.com they will give
you some discounted um
relationship counseling give them a
shout if you can't get to in-person
counseling there
thank you so much for the call candace
we are so excited and proud of you keep
us
abreast on your journey give us a shout
as you make that uh journey